So next game against
Alex,
well maybe we can get by
without G3. Let's vary it a bit.
Here he takes a lot of time
for the first
moves.
Let's do
E3. The variation is also quite
interesting. White has now dispensed with d4 for the time being
an idea is now the runner
F5 is not so good if CD5 and lady B3 it
is already in
Slavic the typical answer to that
aha okay lets go straight after lady
B3 black now has the problem
B7 and
D5 so that's like lady C7 or  Queen
C8 I simply take away D5
and WoW yes, that extremely weakens the
white
squares, the question is directly Bishop B5
or knight
E5 first, well if the chess goes to Bishop
D7 I can just take D5 so
it will probably be knight yes knight
bd7 is also there  D5 from black
resign okay, short and painless, it's
just a pawn, but of course it's not nice